in a recent video we discussed
polynomial equations or functions
basically anything that looks like this
X raised to a power we explained if you
graph these things the solution or the
root or the zero to that polynomial can
be easily seen as the point or points
where the plot crosses the x axis
professor Eisenbud also showed us that
an equation to an odd power must have
extreme points down here and up here
meaning at some point it must cross the
x axis so all polynomials to an odd
degree have at least one root among the
real numbers may be more if we get a
little kink like this great but what
about even degreed polynomials for
example this one well that's never going
to cross the x-axis I mean are there
polynomials for which there are no
solutions or strap yourselves in because
thinking about that is leading us
towards one of the most important
theorems in all of mathematics let's do
it
so I'm going to start with that equation
that equation of even degree that didn't
have any roots f of x equals x squared
plus one and that's not lost cause
that is not a lost cause people probably
have heard of the square root of -1 is a
very famous mathematician Sir Michael
attea who says that the square root of
-1 I is the most important single
invention in all of mathematics
it certainly solves this equation
because if I claim that I have I equals
square root of -1 then by definition I
is a root of that polynomial but there
is no oil here we haven't got we haven't
got an I so we have to find out where I
live and by the time of Gauss in 1800 it
was pretty well understood that you
should think of a plane of numbers
called the complex plane and if you put
in axes there will be a real axis and a
complex and one won't be in its
comfortable place there and I will be
here and you can do ordinary arithmetic
on these things you write some number
people usually use Z for some reason for
complex numbers so Z would be a certain
real part a and a certain imaginary part
maybe B and then I would write Z equals
a the real part plus bi the imaginary
part and complex numbers you multiply
them just the way you think if I want to
multiply 1 plus 2i times 2 minus I let's
say and I just multiply them in parts
just as you would an algebraic
expression if I were X you can do
arithmetic so I can plug any complex
number the things in this plane are
called complex numbers things like Z I
can just plug them into any polynomial
and I get another complex number because
I can multiply them and I can add them
to do all the things that I have to do
I can also divide them and they satisfy
all the comfortable laws of arithmetic
like commutativity a times b is
times a and all those things I get but
just comfortable arithmetic and I can
use them in polynomials if I do this I
might want to separate the source of the
polynomial the place where the exes live
with the values the place where the f of
X is live so I'm going to use a red
plane for that one and now if I draw it
like this so here's the again real axis
and the imaginary axis let's call the
imaginary axis not because it isn't
there it's just as real as the real axis
but the numbers on it are the pure
imaginary numbers the ones without any
real part and then I can do things like
squaring the number I can for example I
could square I and I would record the
value of the square over here so for
instance if my polynomial F let's use
green for the polynomial so if I have F
of a blue X is a red x squared for
instance then F of I would be I squared
which by definition is minus one so I
would I would say that if sort of takes
this point on the real axis over here
here's here's F the green line over to
the minus one point there so I think of
F as taking each point in this plane to
some point in that plane so if I want to
think about the roots of a polynomial
now a polynomial is one of these things
that takes a point here to a point here
and the roots are the points in the blue
plane that it takes to the zero point in
the red plane right in the middle of the
articles right in the middle right here
zero that's our goal here's the
fundamental theorem of algebra it says
this is dooty Gauss again I'd like to
write the word theorem about 18-hundred
I forget the exact date he's pretty
happy that gap Scott wasn't he was
pretty good yeah people always like to
say well he's no cows but that's not a
not much of an insult anyway
the theorem says that
any polynomial with complex coefficients
can i spell coefficients yes having
degree D that is the polynomial not the
coefficients has at least one complex
root but actually it follows from that
that it has d complex roots computed
with multiplicity but let's just say has
at least one complex root and we don't
have to talk about multiplicities and
this is the fundamental theorem of
algebra because it's the basic
connection between algebra and geometry
roots are points somewhere so they're
geometric objects and polynomials are
algebraic objects so this is this is the
connection and makes one without a break
geometry work it makes me happy because
I'm an algebraic geometer it gives me
something interesting to do so what
you're saying is there's no polynomial
that I could concoct that you wouldn't
be able to find roots for as long as
you're allowed to have complex numbers
in your tool belt that's right except
for you're saying that I could find them
I'm going to show you they exist I'm not
going to find them for you if you want
to actually find the root then Newton's
method of fastest descent things that
numerical methods are very powerful but
it's hard to find roots of polynomials
much harder than proving they exist so
I'm just going to prove they exist so
how can we do that we can't do this
trick with lines but we can do a trick
that's a lot like it and for that I have
to explain something about what happens
when you multiply complex numbers so I
think of a complex number here's my blue
complex plane and here's a complex
number so I think of it I like to think
of it as a vector drawn from the origin
and if I think of the vector the vector
really has a length and then once I've
told you the length which is called the
absolute value of the complex number so
Z so if you know the Pythagorean theorem
you know the length of this vector has
gotten by taking the square of the real
part plus the square of the imaginary
part and taking the square root of that
so it's so if Z is a plus bi and the
absolute value of Z I'll write it as
that magnitude it's called is the square
root of a squared plus B squared
just Pythagorean theorem now there's
another thing that you need to determine
where that vector is and that's the
angle let's call it theta let's say we
knew that the magnitude was 1 then we
could compute the sine of theta and the
cosine of theta and if the magnitude
were 1 if this were of length 1 then the
sine which is the opposite side over the
hypotenuse would just be the opposite
side of the triangle which is the
imaginary part and the real part would
be the cosine of the angle so when I
multiply things multiply complex numbers
I'm doing these tricks with the real and
imaginary parts some should think of
that as something happening to sines and
cosines and if you remember your high
school trigonometry which I certainly
don't then there's some addition law for
sines and cosines and it comes out to
saying this if I take two complex
numbers Z and a W here's W and I take
their the angles let's call that one sy
then when I multiply them I multiply
their lengths I multiply the magnitudes
and I add the angles so I would take sy
and then I would add theta to it and I
would get something this way and the
length would be out here someplace right
so this is Z times W so it's really easy
to multiply complex numbers
geometrically you just multiply the
lengths and add the angles and add some
formula which you can figure out put its
I'm going to take it for granted
now we're ready to go and I want to take
an arbitrary polynomial do you have more
of this nice paper Brady
and I want to think of this as going
from a blue complex plane here's one
here's I to a red complex plane say Dave
before we go to video before when you
were doing this right we had two axes
yes here you're representing to eat this
this is one axis and this as the other
axis if we want to make a real graph
like that we need to do it in four
dimensional space and it's hard to
imagine four dimensional space I want to
graph this function I want to tell you
what happens when I buy X and I want to
find the point here which we're at least
to convince you that there is a point a
blue point which will go to zero on the
red side so that's what I want
where is that point going to come from
how am I going to find a point which
does that for one exists to prove one
exists so I start by scratching my head
and thinking I don't know anything about
this polynomial just like before but I
do know that the I do know the leading
term that's X to the N and I know if X
is very big that's likely to be dominant
on the other hand if X is very small I
can do something - if X is zero then the
value will be seen so I know that the
zero point over here in the blue plane
goes to C over in the red planet so
here's a nice red C let's say C is down
here C is a complex number so it's just
someplace in that plane and I know that
0 goes there now that's not terribly
helpful because I wanted to get a point
to go to 0 not to go to see
so what get whales do I know I I know
that just as before if I take X to have
enormous ly large magnitude then X to
the end we'll have that magnitude to the
nth power that'll be much much much
bigger the next to mine
the N minus one so for really large X's
takes is way out and a big big circle
around this those are the X is with big
magnitude so this is magnitude of X much
bigger than 0 and now it's a circle
because it could have any argument it
could have any angle I know that X to
the N will be even bigger I'm going to
shrink the scale on this red plane so
that I don't have to draw it off the off
the table but it'll go to some huge
circle now what will happen when I take
X and I take a walk with X I think of it
as a dog on a leash and I lead it around
the circle so we know what happens the
magnitude remember I'm pretending that
this polynomial is X to the end because
it's like exeunt the magnitude will stay
the magnitude of X to the end the same
thing it was before so we will walk
around this circle and the real
polynomial will stay close to the circle
it'll sort of dance around like a dog
would on a leash after all it's
something else is happening though as I
move X around this one moves n times as
fast because I'm multiplying the angles
by n so it actually goes around n times
for the purposes of this proof it's
enough to good to know that it just goes
around but we'll see why the N is
important there too so as I move around
here once I move around the circle
actually many times okay that was nice
but did it help not obvious
now comes the trick here's the rest of
the proof once you see this you you just
know it's right I'm going to shrink the
blue circle down to the point 0 little
by little and I'm going to watch what
happens on the right hand side on the
right hand side this circle and remember
the real values of the function we're
dancing around this circle somehow but
there are nice continuous curve that
meets up to itself again this circle
will begin to shrink too because I know
that when x is zero or very small this
circle has to be very close to C so
somehow
the circle shrinks down in all
directions in some very uneven way but
at the end of the day it forms a little
circle around C if X is performing a
little circle around zero now in that
process somewhere this this circle has
to pass through the origin and that's
where I catch my roots so somewhere
along the line as it shrinks I have to
see a picture like that and that's the
point which is which I was looking for
that point happened maybe from over here
and it will be a point on a small sort
of smaller circle here where this
function actually goes to zero where it
has zero value we said that it really
goes around n times so actually this
path is going around n times and as I
shrink it will keep going around n times
so there'll be n of these curves that go
that move through the point one at a
time or maybe all at once and so they'll
be actually n roots and so that's the
full fundamental theorem of algebra
if you're still watching this video
you've got the sort of attention span
that makes me think you might enjoy the
hello internet podcast which features
fellow youtuber CGP grey and myself we
talk about all sorts of things very
often we talk about what it's like
making YouTube videos if you'd like to
find out more check out the links I'll
put things in the video description